so Warren Buffett allows uh Dominic Sue
to Shadow him for several weeks the NFL
star shared his three key takeaways
let's go into what his key three
takeaways worth spending time with d-man
d myth The Legend This is a Business
Insider story so the Tampa Bay Buccaneer
player said every meeting was a hundred
times more valuable than an NBA the
football player took three key takeaways
from the billionaire that have
underpinned his approach to business and
investing ever since those were to keep
things simple that's number one
focus on passions and people that's
number two and always read learn and
remain curious about the world let me
say that one more time keep things
simple focus on passions and people
always read learn and remain curious
about the world the six foot four 305
pound lineman also joked about a stage
armed wrestling matches with Buffett in
recent years no matter how many times we
do it I still can't beat him he tweeted
must be all that Coca-Cola Sue said in
general he tries to catch up with
Buffett every quarter and he's gearing
up for an investing career after retires
from football and wants his mentors
advice thoughts publicity stunt and it
doesn't work for me okay really it's a
Duo publicity set I am so not interested
in this and I'll tell you why
okay ndama can sue what's he known for
he's known for being probably the
dirtiest NFL player of our possibly okay
nasty like he could have ended careers
he did not give a damn he's stomping on
people's hands and he was a very dirty
player now Warren Buffett is trying to
rehabilitate His Image he's had a bad
year if you ask me every time he's kind
of a lot I mean he he's kind of getting
branded as a guy that you'd be surprised
if he can make his own oatmeal and get
dressed in the morning right he's he's
in his 90s so I think this is an
opportunity that he was thinking to
rehabilitate His Image a little bit in
the public eye
um and Dominican Sue went to the
university the University of Nebraska so
you're wondering where did this
connection even come from but why do we
care that ndamukin Sue wants to be an
investor how is he even he's not even
relevant as a football player anymore
let alone someone that's going to Branch
off and into the uh investment world I
think it was just it was an elaborate
attempt for both of these guys to grab
some good publicity and then if you look
at this I mean Warren Buffett it is a
genius okay he's probably one of the
sharpest people of the last hundred
years I mean you don't accidentally do
what he's done he's unbelievable but all
this stuff that even his three key
takeaways had no substance to him they
were so basic and and obvious so I I
don't think this helped either of them I
think if you objectively look at it you
can kind of see through it so I think if
there's a publicity stunt that Warren
Buffett wants to do if that's what
you're going with you got to pick
someone better than indomie can sue like
that ain't exactly head like if you're
saying Tom Brady you know shadowed and
Dominican uh Warren Buffett for the last
few years that'd be like holy [ __ ]
there's a story there this is like all
right he's a football player I get it
the Nebraska uh
um connection right there I
the the biggest thing here is like this
happened in 2010
it was 11 years ago so I was like why
the hell is this even a story you hit
the nail on the head the Nebraska thing
he was one of the best players ever to
come out of Nebraska he is one of the
dirtiest players in the NFL I don't know
what you know why he couldn't clean up
his act there what I will say is I know
you're saying that I have that have that
Warren Buffett's having a bad year I
know you made a fun that he can't make
his own oatmeal however I think part of
the problem with Warren Buffett is the
the argument is that he might be a
little out of touch these days with
today's investor meaning a lot of young
gen Z Millennials are all right
yeah they're all about the Bitcoin or
the meme stuff when I interviewed him he
did not hold back from calling him out
so
um you know it's funny a lot of that
criticism came before the Bitcoin and
crypto crash you know a few months ago
because crypto's gone and the specific
argument is you you have an outperformed
S P 500 in the last 15 years so it's not
even a Bitcoin thing sure yeah it's you
haven't beaten S P 500 how does hanging
with ndamukin Sue make you hip well it
does I mean I I think it was a Nebraska
connection I think you hit the nail on
the head I think to wrap this all up to
tie it over to you if you have the
opportunity to Shadow Warren Buffett you
go freaking do that boom bottom line I
mean so I think look to to get a little
you know sportsy here
you know a large percentage of NFL
players go straight up broke within
three to five years of retirement I
think 50 of NBA players go broke within
five years of retirement so if this is
what it takes to basically say hey look
I'm playing in the NFL and I shadowed
freaking Warren Buffett one of the
greatest investors of all time great
arguably the greatest investor of all
time let me take some of these examples
let me take some of these lessons
what does Warren Buffett do for fun
what does Warren Buffett do I think he
actually has fun just doing investing I
think he loves to get it he's like
wakeboarding go on here let's find out
Tony uh go go on this Warren Buffett's
favorite hobby if you go down there well
you saw one go back go back can I go
back top thing Warren Buffett's favorite
hobby
approach investing it's a hobby that you
generously enjoys okay go back to the 25
things you didn't know about Warren
Buffett let's see what if we first
thought he bought he was 11 keep going
go up okay first talking about he was 11
years old he made 53 000 by the age of
16. by the way that's in a different era
he was rejected by Harvard Business
School interesting okay keep going see
what number four is we're looking for
fun
little faster Kai he eats like a
six-year-old uh he lived in the same
house since 1958 his father-in-law told
him cannot read that guy his
father-in-law told him
his father-in-law told him he would fail
nice that's always a good motivator
people will pay millions to have lunch
with them true somebody paid 4.57
million dollars like a couple years ago
in 2013 Buffett earned 37 million
dollars a day rough nearly 94 percent of
his wealth was earned after he turned
60. big motivator never give up keep
going wow number 10 uh uh he never
tweeted before he's never tweeted before
that's cool keep going uh 11 Buffett
owns 20 suits but has never paid for
anything he spends 80 percent of his day
reading fantastic uh Buffett will give
an employee million dollars every year
for the rest of his life his or her life
if they can guess the NCAA sweet 16
teams that's pretty fast there's a hobby
right there he likes March Madness
that's right that's a good point that's
a good thing right there he ditched his
flip phone for an iPhone in 2020. 20 20.
he takes a dozen kids to Dairy Queen
every Sunday I don't know that's cool
Buffett rarely emails okay keep going 17
he plays
Buffett pledged to donate 85 percent of
his Berkshire Berkshire Hathaway stock
to charitable foundations okay
he was the awarded the presidential
medal of freedom by Barack Obama out of
all investing Legends Buffett has the
same best track record for beating the
market impressive his face was on Cherry
Coke cans in China in China okay he
doesn't follow anyone on Twitter he's a
big fan of Breaking Bad wow that's a
good look keep going is that him that's
actually him that's actually the coolest
picture of Warren Buffett I've ever seen
that's actually coolest picture he likes
to joke around okay we know that he
looks to a poem when markets decline no
one can tell you when those will happen
emotionally there's no extraordinary
opportunities if you can keep your head
when all about you are losing theirs
when all about you are losing uh theirs
if you can wait and not be tired of
waiting if you can think and not make
thoughts your aim if you can trust
yourself when all men doubt you yours is
is the Earth and everything that's in it
okay all right cool do we have another
one can I can I make it here's how your
mind can play tricks on you and your
eyes if you could go back to that list
Kai go back to the very bottom of it go
back to number 25 take a quick glance at
number 25 and then look away I literally
when I first saw that I thought he looks
to porn I thought that's what it said he
looks important
this morning good for you
highlighter does their stories they wait
for number 25 all right so when Tom
Zander spent time with him he noticed
how much porn he watched that's probably
what history I gotta tell you when I
hung out with Warren Buffett all we did
is watch porn that's all we did I can
actually see you doing that Pat was
wondering what he does for fun I don't
know there we go okay all right so yeah
we have plan to learn what's that he
plays Bridge though good for him he
doesn't play bad I mean nothing makes
you seem more out of touch than coming
out you hang out with ndamukin too I
mean that's all you need to know there's
like 200 I feel like that's in touch
you're hanging with Okay so let's
continue so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]